so people what kind of design principles
or design thinking goes into the product
of Optimizely
sure so two things come to mind that I
think have served us well from the
beginning when we started Optimizely to
see our competitors products you had to
go through a multi-step sales cycle
which was really frustrating and so we
had no name we had no reputation we had
no salespeople either and so we built
our product in such a way that anybody
could go to Optimizely calm and enter
their website and immediately get the
feeling for what it was like to use our
product and I like to think of that as
putting our product where our mouth is
you know and that forced us to design
something that was easy enough to use
that anybody could get it because the
product was the salesperson initially
and the second one I think that that
really really served as well was this
idea of enabling the novice but
empowering the expert and that you know
that comes through when you look at our
product we've built a visual editor so
whether you're whether you're looking at
a website or a mobile application you
can use your mouse you can drag things
around you can change text you get a lot
of simple things without having to
understand code at all but we're
engineers and we were never really all
that trustful of WYSIWYG editors like
that like you know we you know typically
use Microsoft Word for that reason and
so to satisfy our own itch there we also
made it possible for anybody to go under
the hood and see exactly the code that
we were generating as a result of all
this visual stuff and that sort of that
made it possible for a marketer to go in
and use it but also their web developer
to go in and see exactly what's going on
we found that that's one of our most
consistently used features to our
surprise